hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all the
major problems of the world and so to
help you on your journey today I'm going
to talk about the seven must watched TV
shows for entrepreneurs number one for
me is the product it's a show put on by
CNBC with Marcus lemonis Marcus is an
angel investor and he goes in and he
invests his own money into failing
businesses and tries to turn them around
it's part entertainment in part
education and he also breaks things down
and really easy to understand ways so
that even if you're just getting started
as an entrepreneur you may not have a
total comprehension of you know finances
and balance sheets and income statements
and all that stuff he makes it easy for
you to understand and so it's a must
watch number one most important one that
I think controversy to pay attention to
[Music]
number two for me is Silicon Valley this
is more of a comedy show it's loosely
based around things that happen to the
contrary it's meant as a spoof on the
businesses and the entrepreneurs and
investors that are all down there kind
of in their own different world it's
extra funny for me because I used to be
a venture capitalist and so I come from
that world a little bit and understand
it I think if you are not from the world
as much or you might be English as a
second language or you may not have the
context it may not be a great show for
you Nina as an example doesn't like the
show though I have to watch it by myself
that's it but if you want to learn a
little bit about the venture capital
community it has some fun laughing at it
Silicon Valley's worth checking it
[Music]
number three is billions is a pretty new
show that came out I think you're in
season two right now I love watching
this show it's another one where Nina
won't watch it with me I think some of
the language can be really fast as well
and hard to keep up with and if you
don't really know the stock market and
how the rules kind of work and the
players there and may not be interesting
for you but it's basically about this
guy who's a billionaire who manipulates
stock markets to his own benefit
and this District Attorney who's always
trying to catch him and beat him and
send him to jail and the kind of fight
that they go through and webs they try
to leave for each other and traps they
put each other into I really like the
show and I think it's worth checking out
[Music]
dude you totally hacked in alright go
now before Evan finds out hey guys it's
Marcus here from affiliate marketing
dude and today I'm bringing you the
fourth best show on TV - what if you are
an entrepreneur and as you could tell by
now I've hacked into this presentation
to show you mr. robot mr. robot is a
great show that talks about
entrepreneurship life mental issues and
all kinds of things like that and the
reason I chose it first and foremost is
because of the mental struggle that
Elliott goes through he's a guy he's a
computer hacker and he's going through
this mental struggle constantly to get
the things done that he wants to do and
one of the quotes that I like from this
very quotable show is by Elliot himself
he says sometimes I dream of saving the
world saving everybody from the
invisible hand the one that brands us
with an employee badge the one that
forces us to work for them the one that
controls us every day without us knowing
it but I can't stop it I'm not that
special I'm anonymous I'm just alone now
this is a struggle that entrepreneurs
have all the time feeling like what they
do isn't going to make a difference but
one of the quotes I have on my desk here
in my office is something I came up with
years ago that says from this desk I can
reach the world and in today's day and
age with technology as an entrepreneur
most of the struggle you are going to
have is a mental struggle whether you do
something or don't do something and it's
the struggle of decisions and this show
is ripe with examples of deciding and
the mental struggle and how businesses
can go bad and how businesses can go
good and what you can do as an
individual to make a difference another
quote that I like from mr. robot talks
about the life of hacking and how a
computer works this also goes into the
mindset of the entrepreneur the quote is
there's a saying the devil's that is
strongest when we're looking the other
way
like a program running in the background
silently while we're busy doing other
stuff how many programs do you have
saying I can't I won't I'm not good
enough I don't have enough money I'm not
strong enough and these things limit us
they're like a program running in the
back of our brain as if it's been hacked
by society and by life in general and by
our experiences trying to stop us from
doing what we want to do and I think a
big point that this show points out is
that those background processes those
thoughts that have been implanted in our
brain we don't have to listen to them we
can change the world one step at a time
do what we were born to do and be the
entrepreneur we've dreamed of being
markets from affiliate marketing dude
over and out back to the oven
[Music]
number five is Shark Tank you guys
probably are familiar with it a super
hit TV show and one of really grateful
for because it helped put
entrepreneurship on the map it's fun to
tune in and watch some of the ideas that
are pitched sometimes they're crazy and
you laugh at them sometimes between
inches to see the Sharks fighting with
each other and the drama that happens
but for me I really like to see how
these successful investors break down a
deal what they look for how they
negotiate the deals what the counters
are for the entrepreneurs has seen the
pitches I think it's really good
business education as well as providing
some entertainment value too so if you
haven't already seen it I don't know
what rock you're living under but it's
definitely worth checking out
[Music]
number six is suits this is a funny show
this actually filmed here in Toronto
whoo and City it's about a law firm it's
about these Harvard law students and you
know one of the lawyers super successful
is the killer always wins
and always has you know ton of attitude
and confidence Eagle bravado and the new
upstart guy doesn't have as much
confidence but it also has a lot of
heart and caring and wants to fight for
the little guy and his boss doesn't
really see it all the time there's a lot
of fun banter in between them and a lot
of movie references and pop-culture
references that you may understand I'm a
slight on the radar but it's a good show
it's a kind of I don't know I like
because you see businesspeople doing
their thing having confidence in bravado
and we
in their in their arena and so I worth
checking out
season one at least I love season one it
was amazing as it got out I think
they're in season six or seven now the
in between seasons felt like they went a
little too heavy on the drama for me too
much drama happen in each episode but
then they kind of brought it back to
this last season I'm really enjoying
again so watch season one and see if you
like it if you do it's worth continuing
on and number seven is Planet of the
apps this is yet to be released show I
heard about it from Gary Vaynerchuk it's
him Gweneth Paltrow will.i.am and
Jessica Alba and they are basically
judging people who are pitching the apps
so people have to go on this escalator
ride down and while they're on the
escalator they have to pitch their idea
and one of the four judges has to say I
like you and then the judges pick a
winner and they personally work with
that person to help them build their app
and it's some competition to see who
ends up winning from all the apps and
the coaching with the with the experts
on there so it hasn't come out I've only
seen that the trailer but there's some
interesting people on it and I'm looking
forward to seeing the she'll come out
and anything that's supporting
entrepreneurship generally I'm a pretty
big banner so that's my take on a
7-month watch shows for entrepreneurs
I'd love to know what did you guys think
have you watched all seven of these you
have a favorite did I miss an eight nine
ten that you want to add to the list
leave it down the count's below I'm
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to Kevin fielder
from Kevin fielder de thank you so much
Kevin for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and making the animated
review on it as well I'm so glad you
loved this and I really appreciate the
support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
cease